c'est parti en 3 minutes top chrono
voici les 10 événements importants de
2024 dans les Yvelines en sport la
Course au Soleil parinis partira pour la
15e année consécutive des yelin le 3
mars les coureurs s'élanceront des
Mureaux le lendemain ils partiront de
toiri qui succédera à pogachar le
vainqueur de l'an dernier réponse début
mars c'est l'événement politique de
l'année 2024 l'Europe aux urnes les
élections européennes auront lieu le 9
juin au total 720 députés européens
seront élus donct 81 pour la France au
mois de juin également il soufflera
comme un air d'Interville du côté de
Rambouillet l'agglomération organise ses
premières Olympiades entre les 36
communes de son territoire tir à la
corde pétanque basket ou encore
fléchettes les inscriptions sont encore
ouvertes des Olympiades pour se mettre
dans l'ambiance des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 3 jours
avant la cérémonie d'ouverture la flamme
olympique sera de passage dans les
Yvelines dans huit communes une centaine
de porteurs yvelinois participeront à ce
relais jusqu'au domaine de Madame
ellisabeth à Versailles pour l'allumage
symbolique et vous l'aurez compris c'est
l'événement de l'année 2024 pendant un
mois les ivelines vont accueillir
plusieurs disciplines des Jio versaill
va recevoir les épreuves d'équitation de
paraéquitation et de pentathlon modne
dans le parc du château le vélodrome
national va de son côté héberger les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et de
paracyclisme à une centaine de mètres ce
seront les courses de BMX toujours à 50
ans en Eveline le VTT prendra place sur
la colline d'éencour pour le golf
rendez-vous sur le green national de
guyancour enfin les courur du marathon
et les cyclistes sur route passeront
également dans le département en
septembre un site unique en France
devrait également sortir de terre je
vous parle du village 100 % inclusif
Agora à Montini le BR autonux handicap
cognitif psychique ou physique la
structure assurera la prise en charge de
tous ceux qui souhaitent devenir
autonome feu d'artifice fête forain
braderie produit du terroir c'est un
incontournable du territoire la foire de
Houdan est l'une des plus anciennes
foires d'Europe avec sa
954e édition un rendez-vous pour goûter
le fameux pâté de Houdan et après la
foire le cirque Acrobat clown magicien
ils viennent de partout dans le monde
pour participer au Festival
International du Cirque des Mureaux une
date importante pour les artistes car en
cas de bonne appréciation du Jurie ils
présenteront leur numéro à travers le
monde et c'était il y a 3 ans mais ils
seront jugés à partir du 12 novembre
personnes sont mises en cause dans
l'assassinat du professeur Samuel paatti
deux seront notamment jugés pour
complicité d'assassinat terrorist
l'infraction la plus lourde enfin en
2024 les barrières de péage vont
disparaître tout du moins sur la 14 au
péage de montaesson et de chamboursi et
sur la 13 au péage de bûchel cependant
il faudra toujours payer mais sur
Internet les barrières seront remplacé
par des portiqu automatiques qui
scanneront les plaques
d'immatriculation